comprenez vous que nrj12 suspendre
l'émission qu'il arrêtait les anges
après tout ce qu'on a appris harcèlement
violences mignan à drogue alcool alors
on à sarah fresu qui est avec nous c'est
la star de cette télé réalité depuis
plus d'une semaine les gens sont dans
l'oeil du cyclone en cause des
accusations comme j'ai dit d'acharnement
de harcèlement de sexisme au sein du
programme qui sera encouragée par la
production
une polémique est née en train après un
clash entre deux candidats et qui a
trouvé un écho sur les réseaux sociaux
la polémique enfle et a tellement fait
que selon nos informations la chaîne
donc aurait décidé de mettre en suspens
le programme
guillaume genton puis c'est quoi
l'histoire alors en fait nrj12 devait
tourner après cette saison des anges une
saison supplémentaire des vacances des
anges avec un concept légèrement
différent autour de l'amour qui
ressemble un peu au prince de l'amour et
suite à toutes ces polémiques parce que
selon nos informations la chaîne prend
très à coeur ces polémiques et les
sujets qui sont notamment le harcèlement
la chaîne a décidé de stopper le
tournage il n'aura même pas commencé ça
devait tourner en juin ça devait être
diffusé fin août à la rentrée sur nrj 12
est donc cette nouvelle saison des
vacances des anges ne sera pas diffusée
à la rentrée sur nrj 12
alors les angles on va voir sa femme
clash un clash entre angèle et raphaël
notamment dans cette émission est juste
apprendre à genlis ya et sarah frison
sarah fresu c'est la candidate
emblématique des jantes et gens me sylla
président de l'institut apollo qui lui
veut arrêter toutes les téléréalités
regardez ces partis regarder ce clash
la loi et notamment en italie se passe
avec moi mais je dois complaisent à deux
points des malades à travers des favoris
comme un gadget il fait toute la journée
je t'aimerai j'en ai rien à faire en
tout cas du parc
je vous fais de tram et moi je m'en fous
parce que je te calcule femme a grand
mal à mes efforts à guwahati c'est vous
la fij et de mes deux bordas du monde a
droit
mais je dis merci en tout cas sarah
fresu d'être avec les six ans
[Applaudissements]